what are the chances
that we're actually
in the very kind of system that you're
describing where the the environment and
the brain is being emulated and you're
just replaying an experience when you
were first did a podcast with lex
after and now you know the person that
originally launched this already did
hundreds of podcasts with lex this is
just the first time and you like this
time because there's so much uncertainty
there's nerves it could have gone any
direction
um at the moment we don't have the
technical ability to create
that an emulation so we'd have to be
postulating that in the future we have
that ability and then they choose to
evaluate this moment now no but we're
simulated don't you think we're we could
be in the simulation of that exact
experience right now we wouldn't be able
to know
so
one scenario would be this never really
happened this only happens as a
reconstruction later on yeah that's
different than the scenario this did
happen the first time and now it's
happening again as a reconstruction
second scenario is harder to put
together because it requires this
coincidence where between the two times
we produce the ability to do it
um no but don't you think replay of
memories uh um poor replay
of memories is
something so that might be a possible
thing in the future saying it's harder
than conjure up things from scratch
it's certainly possible so the main way
i would think about it is in terms of
the demand for simulation versus other
kinds of things so i've given this a lot
of thought because you know i first
wrote about this long ago when bostrom
first wrote his papers about simulation
argument and i wrote about how to live
in a simulation
um
and
um
so the key issue is
you know the fraction of creatures in
the universe that are really
experiencing what you appear to be
really experiencing relative to the
fraction that are experiencing it in a
simulation way i.e simulator so
then
the key parameter is at any one moment
in time
creatures at that time many of them most
of them are presumably really
experiencing what they're experiencing
but some fraction of them are
experiencing some past time
where that past time is being remembered
via their simulation
so um
to figure out this ratio what we need to
think about is basically
two functions one is how fast in time
does the number of creatures grow
and then how fast in time does the
interest in the past decline
because at any one time people will be
simulating different periods in the past
with different emphasis based on the way
you think so much
that's exactly right yeah so
if if the first function grows slower
then the second one declines
then in fact your chances of being
simulated
are low
yes so the key question is how fast does
interest in the past decline relative to
the rate at which the population grows
with time does this correlate to you you
earlier suggested that the interest in
the future increases over time
are those correlated interest in the
future versus interest in the past like
why are we interested in the past but
the simple way to do is as you know like
google engrams has a way to type in a
word and see how interested in client
declines arises over time right yeah you
can just type in a year and get the
answer for that if you type in a
particular year like 1900 or 1950 you
can see with google engram how interest
in that year increased up until that
date and decreased after it yep and you
can see that interest in a date declines
faster
than does the population grow with time
that is brilliant
and so that's so interesting to have the
answer
wow
and that was your argument against
not against to this particular aspect of
the simulation how much uh
past simulation there will be a replay
of past memories first of all if we
assume that like simulation of the past
is a small fraction of all the creatures
at that moment yes right
and then it's about how fast now some
people have argued plausibly that maybe
most interest in the past falls with
this fast function but some unusual
category of interest in the fast won't
fall that fat quickly and then that
eventually would dominate so that's a
other hypothesis some category so that
that very outlier specific kind of yeah
okay yeah yeah yeah like really popular
kinds of memories like
second probably second in a trillion
years there's some small research
institute that tries to randomly select
from all possible people in history or
something yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah so questions how big is this
research institute and how big is the
future in a trillion years right and
that's that would be hard to say but if
we just look at the ordinary process by
which people simulate recent
errors so if you look at well i think
it's also true for movies and plays and
video games overwhelming they're
interested in the recent past
there's very few video games where you
play someone in the roman empire
right
even fewer where you play someone in the
ancient egyptian empire
yeah just different it should decline
very quickly but every once in a while
that's brought back
um but yeah you're right i mean just if
you look at the mass of entertainment
movies and games it's it's focusing on
the present recent past and maybe some i
mean where does science fiction fit into
this because
um it's sort of uh
what is science fiction i mean it's a
mix of the past and the present and some
kind of manipulation of that right to uh
make it more efficient for us to ask
deep philosophical questions about
humanity the closest genre to science
fiction is clearly fantasy fantasy and
science fiction many bookstores and even
netflix or whatever categories they're
just lumped together
so clearly they have a similar function
so that the function of fantasy is more
transparent than the function of science
fiction so use that as your guide
what's fantasy for it's just
to take away the constraints of the
ordinary world and imagine stories with
much fewer constraints right that's what
fantasy is you're much less constrained
what's the purpose to remove constraints
is it to escape
from the harshness of the constraints of
the real world
or is it to just remove constraints in
order to explore some
some get a deeper understanding of our
world what do you what is that i mean
why do people read fan i'm not a i'm not
a
a cheap fantasy reading kind of person
so i need to uh
one story that sounds plausible to me is
that there are sort of these
deep story structures that we
love and we want to realize and then
many details of the world get in their
way
fantasy takes all those obstacles out of
the way and lets you tell the essential
hero story or the essential love story
whatever essential story you want to
tell um the the reality and constraints
are not in the way
and so science fiction can be thought of
as like fantasy except you're not
willing to admit that it's not can't be
true so the future gives the excuse of
saying well it could happen
and you accept some more reality
constraints for the for the illusion at
least that it maybe it could really
happen
maybe it could happen and that it
stimulates the image the imagination
is something really interesting about
human beings
and it seems also to be an important
part of creating really special things
is to be able to first imagine them uh
with you and nick bostrom
where do you land on the simulation and
all the
mathematical ways of thinking it and
just the thought experiment of it are we
living in a simulation
that was the just discussion we just had
that is you should grant the possibility
of being a simulation you shouldn't be
100 confident that you're not you should
certainly grant a small probability the
question is how large is that
probability oh you're saying we would be
i misunderstood because i thought our
discussion was about replaying things
that already happened right but the
whole question is
right now is that what's what i am
am i actually a replay from some distant
future but it doesn't necessarily need
to be a replay it could be a totally new
you could be you don't have to be right
but clearly i'm in a certain era with a
certain kind of world around me right so
either this is a complete fantasy or
it's a past of somebody else in the
future
but
no it could be a complete fantasy though
it could be right but then you might and
then you have to talk about what's the
frank fraction of complete fantasies
right
i would say it's easier to generate a
fantasy than to replay a memory right
higher history we just look at the
entire history of everything we should
say sure but most things are real most
things aren't fantasies right therefore
the chance that my thing is real right
so so the simulation argument works
stronger about sort of the past we say
ah but there's more future people than
there are today so you being in the past
of the future makes you special relative
to them which makes you more likely to
be in a simulation right if we're just
taking the full count and saying in all
creatures ever what percentage are in
simulations probably no more than ten
percent
see so what's the good argument for that
that most things are real yeah because
uh
says the other way right
in a competitive world in a world where
people like have to work
and have to get things done then they
have a limited budget for
leisure
and so
you know leisure things are less common
than work things like real things right
that that that's just
but if you look at the stretch of
history in the universe
doesn't the ratio of leisure increase
i
it's not where we isn't that the forward
right but now we're looking at the
fraction of leisure which takes the form
of something where the person doing the
leisure doesn't realize it now there
could be some fraction but that's much
smaller right
yeah okay
cool as forward
or somebody is clueless in the process
of supporting this this leisure right it
might not be the person leisuring
somebody they're a supporting character
or something but still that's got to be
a pretty small fraction of leisure
you